Andy.
Hey, Justin.
Good time.
Long time. I haven't seen you here, man.
Yeah, got some.
Cancer problems here in the house, so...
Hello.
Need to attend that.
Gotcha.
So, black line didn't renew anymore, right?
Let's talk about that offline.
Is this recorded already?
Yeah, it is now.
Sorry.
Big.
Who is going to be joining the Kobe library?
Natalie, Lee, hopefully, and the new team lead.
Okay.
Hey, Natalie.
Hola, what's up? What's up?
I know.
We were just talking about you.
Oh, that's good. Glad to know.
Okay.
We are joining from our conference room.
Hey, Marky.
A.
Just like, nah, nope.
Hello!
Hello. Hello.
What up? Conference room 5 in the house.
Stupid.
Hey, Reggie. Hey, Jacob.
I.
Hello, hello, hello.
How are you guys? Good. Great.
Doing well, how about yourself?
No.
The same, just busy. Busy is good. Yeah, so probably before we go ahead and proceed with our QBRs, let's just introduce ourselves because I know Jacob and Reggie, I think there's some unfamiliar faces on this call, so might as well introduce ourselves. Again,
Andy, Service Delivery Manager from the Philippines, Primary POC for Planet Depot, working alongside Terrence. Been here for at least, I think, less than a year, six months now. I'm a regular employee. Yay. So I made it. Yeah, so I'll be introducing to you guys our
Made it.
Okay.
Regular laws.
the newly part, newly member of our team here in Manila in a bit. Go ahead, Natalie.
Yep, so I know that we may have met at an event probably here or there, but I'm Natalie. I've been with IT by Design for about 4 1/2 years now. So I'm associate director of our customer experience team. And then on my team, I have Justin, who's here as well. So he'll be the customer success manager out of the Philippines.
for you guys and Justin, you can do a short introduction and then we'll pass it to Mark.
Yes, sure. No worries. So hi guys. So yeah, I'm fairly new as well. So I joined IT by Design around February. So I'm quite fresh, but I'm going to be your new customer success manager. And you know, I can just, I will also be messaging you guys. I'll send you an email just for a quick introduction and if you need any.
thing else outside the scope of Andy, you can reach out to me and Natalie as well. Nice to meet you guys.
All right.
Thank you.
All right, so as you guys all know, we went from Brian as a team lead, and then he left us. And now we recently moved to Rodge. But Rodge is still very much within IT by design. It's just that he's moving into a more senior role now, which is why.
We brought in Mark, so Marky will be bringing in 12 years of experience with an MSP, but I'll let him introduce himself. Go ahead, Marky.
Hi guys. Hi guys. You can call me Marky and.
I just started a week ago here in the ITBD, so I'm looking forward to work with you guys. And I've been in the MSP industry for about 12 years. And being the team lead, aside from being the team lead with the same company, I'm also doing the role for their incident management.
Yeah.
role, which is responsible for P1 and P0 tickets. And also I'm also doing the dispatch coordinator role for them during weekends. So I'm assigning tickets as well for the service desk and also managing the VIP tickets that we are receiving during.
Those days, so yeah.
Cool. Thank you.
PH.
Reggie, do you want to do introduction on your side?
Hi, I'm Reggie. Thanks, Andy, for just throwing me out there. I'm the help best lead. I've been here for three years now.
Yeah.
The.
Yes.
So I think I probably work the closest with Terrence because Terrence works the off shift work later in the day. So if he has anything, I'm normally his escalation point. So before your work experience wise, I've been at MSPs for over 10 years. And then before that,
I think I was doing government contract work.
So, there you go.
You think? It sounds suspicious. Sounds like you were a spy.
Jacob.
PH.
Yeah, he can't recall or disclose.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, may or may not.
I'm Jacob. I'm the new senior IT manager at PD.
Started middle of March, so almost two months.
I've had the pleasure of working with Terrence a few times, but still getting familiar with everything we do here. So I apologize if I have more questions than necessary.
Okay. Thanks, Jacob.
Alright, let me just share my screen.
Let me know if you guys can see it.
Yep.
All right, do you want to do the initial boards, Natalie?
Yeah, absolutely. So thank you guys for joining us for our quarterly business review. This is something we want to make sure that we do every single quarter, and we normally make it pretty easy for you guys. We just turn one of the service calls or monthly reviews into a quarterly review, so we can just look at the data just at a larger scale.
than just outside of the normal service calls. So jump into the agenda for today.
So we already did the welcome, so that's good. We have that out of the way. We'll look at the partnership a little bit. We'll look at the business impact and some value that we've delivered so far with the engineers, go over the performance. I'm sure you'll have some questions along the way here. Go through some key wins and improvements, some growth opportunities, and then we'll look at next quarter as a whole.
just to see where we can support you guys in your business goals there too.
So as far as value drivers here at ITBD by design, I know you guys have the dedicated services with us. And then obviously, you're going to see that it's going to protect your gross profit and just your EBITDA overall, just because the cost of the resources are a little bit lower. And then we help
with maintaining your business continuity. So anytime that you need an engineer, we're a 24 by 7 operation. So any peak or even if there's just something going wrong and you want to seek our expertise on something, you can reach out to us there. And then we make sure that you have that advisement. So when you reach out, there's somebody there that you can talk to.
Any other value drivers that you guys have seen along the way?
Not in my short time here, but...
Yeah, you're like, "I just got here, give me some time."
Yeah, I think you got them all that I can think of.
Open.
All right, so I'll just take this away. So we have like 4 outcomes that we wanted to highlight this quarter. So we were able to stay in ticket closure rate above the SLA target. So 96% across the entire quarter. So that is consistent with handling the queue and the tickets.
that he handles in a week, Terrence was able to reduce a backlog instead of deferring it. So we'll be able to see that in the next few slides. And again, just like what Natalie mentioned, service continuity. So Terrence has delivered an interrupted shift across the entire quarter, 0 absences, 0 leads over 8 consecutive weeks.
even with the shift transition to the after hours as well. Next was end user satisfaction over quarter to quarter. We've improved from 94% to 100% from Jan to Feb window. So we've received positive sentiments.
throughout and adjusted to describe as we did help or Terrence did help Planet Depot significantly. Last but not the least, he expanded his scope in handling without service to creation. So in addition to the standard ticket handling, Terrence did
had a chance to take on Atlas system audit and project tickets during that rollout period, absorbing and added complexity on the experiences that he has, impacting resolution and of course CSAT.
Any questions on this?
Nope, I'm good.
Cool, we just.
A lot.
Natalie.
Yep, so just going through the last quarter, what mattered most for you and then what worked well from your perspective?
I mean, as as recent as...
Like we had our quarterly meeting where we assigned the next quarter's tasks and projects in ClickUp. And I think Terrence, his communication within ClickUp has been very well overnight so that I can follow up with him when I come in. And we're kind of, we have a good back and forth established for him to continue progressing on those projects.
No, that's great, because you guys aren't really probably, there's just a small window of shift overlap, right? Or even, yeah, I guess, yeah, there's a little bit. So the fact that they're able to update and you're able to go in there and know exactly what's going on is awesome.
Yeah.
Like, just two hours.
Got anything that or?
No, I think that's good. I think he really helped with the transition and going into the leadership.
since that was like an urgent need and he did it. So I think that was very helpful to him.
Okay. Yeah, he seems self-sufficient too, which is nice.
All right, well then let's get into the metrics.
All right, let's have a look at his performance review over this quarter. So this is his scope of work on HD team. His focus on active support, help desk, and all the other stuff. And he's working VPM EST.
So just wanted to highlight again, perfect attendance, 8 consecutive weeks. So we just made sure that even though he transitioned to that after hour support, he actually loved it, by the way. You guys know that. He actually loved that schedule. So we were able to keep that momentum going and did not have any depth.
So wanted to highlight also that after a long time of planning, he was able to get that AZ900 certification completed. So he was able to retake it January 20, and he was able to complete that certification. So one thing that he wanted to do next is
SC 900 security certification. So we'll see about that. Next is the shift transition executed without disruption. I mentioned that earlier today. Right after that transition to the after hours, there were no gaps, no service interruption. And again, since he loved that schedule.
He adapted very quickly to the new ticket profile and after hours rhythm.
Last but not the least, you know, consistently recognized with the partners across all review period. So just a bit of a insight, Jacob. Terrence was cited positively in her bi-weekly service reviews for to get close out, customer-facing professionalism.
And even though there's a coaching feedback on ticket hygiene and communication when it comes to the end users, we wanted to, and we've categorized that as a development opportunities as opposed to deficiencies on his end.
Questions?
All right, let's move on.
All right, so we wanted to talk about his ticket to be solved. So for the month of January, he had like 158, Feb for 130 and March, 117. So over January, he achieved 158 closures, averaging 7.5 tickets A day. So our targets in a day is...
Yeah.
8 tickets, 8 to 10 tickets if possible. So Feb and Marsh, there's a bit of a dip for 6 tickets a day and probably an intake reduced from 130 and 117. Again, this is not because of deficiencies on his end. So their resolution still remains stable.
without any block logs and the demand aligned workload optimization throughout is consistent still.
Next is the CSAT. So our target for our CSAT is 90%. So December and January held at 94.74, which is above our target with one okay rating regarding Atlas, if you remember that, Reggie. So Feb and March achieved a perfect
100%, zero and happy and rating across 29 total responses. So we wanted to make sure that CSAT has improved and he did in fact improve it quarter on quarter, which is a strong indicator of the service quality that he provides. Questions before I move along?
Ankur.
All good.
Cool.
All right, so wanted to also highlight this workload versus backlog management. So we wanted to make sure that we also highlighted if there's anything that has left with the ticket that he has handled. So January, he closed 100% of all the tickets that he handled. Zero backlog carried into the next period.
Feb carried a bit of a largest backlog to date, which is 20 tickets, coinciding with the shift transition that we did mid-Feb. And he did recover that March to just six tickets.
moving forward.
Any question?
Call me.
Okay, and engineer efficiency. So we wanted to also show how Terrence is being efficient on a monthly basis. So given that he had like 100% closure rate January and meeting all full ticket demand on the daytime shift, Beb has dipped into 84%.
following the shift change, but then after he acclimated through the change of shift mid-Feb, he was able to recover that to 94% just under the target. So we wanted to make sure that we still have a very efficient engineer throughout, even though
we move them to the after hours and I think we're almost hitting that 100% mark again.
Questions.
I'm good.
Okay. All right. So a total of 379 total tickets this quarter. So I wanted to highlight that Jan is just the strongest month. So we wanted to also see next quarter that he's going to surpass this ticket that he closed this quarter.
Hopefully.
So end user CSAT and the voice of Planet Depot. So again, you already see that we maintained that 100% CSAT, 12 out of 12 surveys rated happy, quality achieved while closing 379 tickets across the quarter, still consistent in service quality.
We hear your feedback on every service call about multiple end user comments, about his responsiveness, technical knowledge, and of course, every time that he's needed, he is there. And last but not least is CSAT trends indicates that there is a high trust and confidence in a day-to-day support delivery firm.
For Planet T. Post.
Again, click rate 5.74. I think I did ask Reggie about this in the past if this is really low, but you did mention that compared to the other staff, it's pretty much high. Did I get that right?
Yeah, because we weren't getting flicks at all for people to do surveys. So just for him to get 12 alone is great because we probably wouldn't even had 12 total before we even went to Team GPS. So nope, you're right.
Yeah.
Gotcha. Thank you very much.
Okay, so moving on to quarter two priorities and recommendation. I think we needed to recalibrate the daily resolution targets. I know that 8 to 10 tickets benchmark was set as a standard. However, I think with the intake now lower and stabilize, and I
think we're going to put him in that shift for quite some time. I think we needed to recalibrate if 8 to 10 tickets is still within that. What do you guys think?
Achievable, maybe.
Hello.
Eight to 10 might be a stretch now, especially with us changing stuff on the ABDs, which most of the most of the people that work on that shift he's on works on the ABDs. So I think once we roll out this fix for the profile issues, I'm gonna say that should probably cut down on some tickets as far as reoccurring. So
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Ohh.
It might drop a little bit low between 8:00 to 10:00, but...
I would say...
Let's leave it there for maybe like a month or so just to get a trend. But if he doesn't make it, we won't hold it against him because if they're not calling, that means they've been trained and taught to do the job and not require help. So we can't.
Sure.
He knows that.
Hold that against him.
I gotcha. So when we have enough data to play around with, then you and I can, including Jacob, can probably talk about it during one of our service calls and see the trend of his tickets intake. Cool.
All right. Next is introduce full project work aligned to the evening shift. I think we did touch about this, Jacob, in the past, wherein we wanted to also highlight that since he is working on Planet Depot's tickets, it's that the support is
really non-billable. But I think I did mention that maybe, I don't know, we can assign him a small project during his 3 P.m. to 11 P.m. shift because I think he has a bit of a time to actually cater those. So I don't know if you can shadow if that's already happening.
So I did give him a few projects to do some audits.
Maybe.
Mhm.
He made great progress quicker than I'm ready to give him more work. So right now he's waiting on me to review what he's done. But we're kind of shifting towards that because of the lower ticket count evenings.
Yeah.
The.
Mhm.
And he's communicative and he'll ask me and he'll let me know when he's done and waiting on next steps. So it's on me right now to provide that.
Okay.
All right, that's good to know. So I think what we wanted to do with the recalibration of the ticket intake and more of so small projects is aligned to what we wanted to do and important to.
Questions so far, no?
Oh.
Okay, so we wanted to also still protect and sustain the 100% CSAT as the volume grows. So we wanted to make sure that the focus on Q2 is to increase, hopefully, the survey participation and put in place early warning checks to make sure that the quality does not.
arrowed just in case the volume picks up a bit. But the volume, I would say it's going to go down just like what he mentioned. Moving to a demand-driven capacity planning. So again, I think this falls out into the small project that has been assigned to him. So instead of
doing fixed daily out, but it would be now recommending to have him do the daily tickets, including the task that he has on those small projects that you get to assign to him. So focus on quarter two is fair targets, quality, recovered value, and making sure that our service model is built for.
long-term, not just today.
Any questions?
Nope, alright.
I'm gonna think we're done, yeah.
Okay.
There is Natalie.
All right. So thanks, guys. I mean, it sounds like in general, Terrence is doing great. I love to hear that. And then you threw in a team GPS plug in there as well. So how is everything going with team GPS?
It's going good.
We use it for CSAT mostly. We did do some project stuff in there at first, but we have a new boss now over there. So we are moving some stuff around, but I feel like we're going to keep it around because of
Yeah.
Okay, are you doing like the meetings and everything in there too?
We haven't done it. Me and him talked about it doing the one-on-one stuff in there, because that was one of the selling points on why we actually did get it. So because I was at Guild It last year, and then they first introduced it. So I liked it for that, or we liked it for that. So I think it's pretty good, but we just have another
Okay.
Yeah.
projects, software that we use as company wide and then for team GPS, it's literally just the IT team that uses it. So some of the projects that we do, it needs to be seen company wide. So that's why we haven't really put a lot of stuff in there for that. But I do like it for the meetings and I do like it for the CSAT because we were using
Akshay, thank you.
customer thermometer at 1st and we literally weren't getting any responses. But since we did over to team GPS and we started getting CSAT information and with it having the values in it, it kind of relates more to the company. So I think people have been more inclined to click on it and do it with it.
Yeah.
having some branding and things in it.
Okay, okay. Are you guys doing the rewards and recognition too?
Yes.
Yeah, we like that one. We like to send each other points in and get the gift cards. If there's anything that you want to know, I don't know, have you had a meeting with Vikram lately just to go over everything with AI?
Maybe before you start like fully rolling out the one-on-one meetings, I'd probably suggest at least meeting with Amit or Keshav and kind of looking at how you can integrate AI into it because it makes it a lot easier.
PH.
We're in a group chat, so whenever I have questions, I go to them first. I don't know if that's the right way or not to do it, but we talk often.
Yeah.
Okay, no, but it's pretty cool, even if you wanted to get a demo of it. So with the one-on-one meetings, it'll actually give you a write-off, a write-out after, and it'll tell you even if like you said something during that meeting that like wasn't compliant. So like there's like the internal analysis that it does for you.
PH.
Yeah, Park. OK.
that obviously the employee is not going to see, but there's a lot of insight that you can get whenever you start using AI in those meetings too.
Let's set up that demo. I was about to say, I'll say something wrong in every meeting, but yeah, we can try it out.
Uh...
Yeah.
Just because my boss has me using Paylocity for the one-on-ones. Oh, you do yours with? And. Okay. I might want to switch to. Team GPS? Yeah. I like it for that. When they initially showed it to us, it was great. Because you can do notes and what you want to talk about, what you want to cover, and then you can have a review of what you did.
No, that's it.
Yeah, why do you?
Keith.
the previous one so you can do like a follow up. So it kind of keeps it organized and keep you on track versus you getting in there and saying, hey, what are we going to talk about today? So.
And it also sends an email to the person that you're talking about, so they acknowledge it right away.
Ohh.
Yep. Yeah, no, it's great. And then another thing that I have to offer you guys, just because you are a partner, I know our bread and butter is always going to be engineering, but you do have access to our talent acquisition team. So if there's anybody, if you're looking for a finance or an accounting role,
any type of operations or admin role, we can search for that for you too. So procurement specialist, purchasing specialist, these are all roles that we have placed with other partners of ours. So it's not like we're just throwing names out there and then go into the market. It's just a little bit of a longer sales cycle at the end of the day, because sometimes they may be working.
somewhere, they have to have their notice put in, but we do try to at least give you the timeline and then you're just a part of that process as we go. So any interest in hiring in different departments or anyone you think I should talk to?
Is this only remote?
For remote position.
Yeah, it would be either out of our Philippines or our India office.
So they would still, they would work in office, but just in.
Ohh.
Philippines, right?
If you guys have something with the positions you regularly scout, I could send it to the rest of the managers if they have any interest in a specific position.
Okay, like, like even just a Helpdesk position or like these AR positions, because normally those are more like ad hoc, but we can, yeah, I can send you like basically the list and then they would just, I would just want their final job description. So once I have that, then I can do the proper alignment and we can go from there.
Mhm.
Just that list would be enough and I'll send it all out and see who's interested.
Cool, I appreciate that. That'd be great. I did notice when I was looking at your account as well, at one point you had somebody named Edelson on the account. So you did have two engineers with us at some point. Do you plan on scaling back up?
Yeah.
Yes and no. Right now they want me to kind of establish our current baseline and see where we're at and then determine
who, what shift our next hire will be. Depending on where that gap is, if it's an overnight, we'll utilize you guys. If it's someone we want in office during the day, then it'll be through us. But I still have to determine that baseline.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, and then even we have our AI by design as well. So even if it's just something that you need help as you're looking to kind of figure out how many people, ticket volume, are you looking at automation too as far as kind of making the service desk a little more efficient?
Yeah.
Okay, what have you guys done so far with AI?
Nothing with AI. I'm kind of looking at all of our software platforms, what we're manually doing that can be automated within each respective platform. I'm basically starting at step one.
Okay. Have you had an assessment done yet?
And then...
Have I no?
Okay, so we give our partners a free AI assessment. So basically what that does is it gives you your maturity level. We just ask you a few questions. It gives you the maturity level. And then we also build out a little bit of a roadmap as far as like what your AI journey would look like. Again, that's free for you guys. And then
if you want help, like actually building it out, we have our automations team. So most of our automation engineers are out of India, but we're even building out our Philippines team as well. Especially, are you using Bruce by chance?
We are not here, but I have demoed with them in previous jobs and MSP and all of them.
Okay, yeah, that's...
Yeah, that's kind of our primary as far as like tools out there right now. A lot of our partners are using Roost and then we work so we are their go-to as far as consulting and we get a lot of project work from them too.
Okay.
So something to think about, like if you're looking to implement it, I think it's like $1,500 on their side. And then we can help you as far as like managing it. We actually have AI engineers as well, I think. And then build it this year, you get the AI accelerator for free to the training.
Are they is there a build it slide? Let's go to the next one.
So this is our, so this is our full AI suite. You can go back to the AI. So this is everything that we're doing with AI right now. So the automation Consulting, I'll set you up so you can get an AI assessment. I'll loop you in with our AI guy, Parth, and then we'll get you with our team to actually run that assessment.
agents. So we'll look at different agents. That's probably what you're looking at right now is like what's super manual right now? What can we build agents for? We have a few agents that we've already built out. We can do some demos for you. So like we have a QA agent. That one's really nice. We have a QBR agent. And then we also have a digital dispatcher.
and different voice agents we can play with as well. So like we have a sales agent on our website, we have a voice agent. Whenever, if you, we don't have people sit on hold, they ask if you want to go to the voice agent and then we'll call them back. So just different ways that you can utilize AI and then it just helps.
using humans where you need to use humans, and then AI can also take care of everything that you're not able to do right now. We're really focusing on like the digital worker helping the human, not so much like replacing jobs, just making it easier for everybody. And also you can get more done.
Another day.
And then the Team GPS piece, I know we talked about a little bit, you'll schedule some time with them so they can walk through all the different agents. So the goal is just to give you guys an idea too and why it makes sense for you to at least do the AI assessment to get started, is our plan is that Team GPS is going to be our agentic platform. So
our goal is we're building all these use cases out where customer zero, right? We want to make sure that things are working and then we've started to sell them. We have several clients right now who were pretty much really ingrained in the AI and the automation of their environment. But what Team GPS is going to do is you can basically just go in there and
be like, oh, I need a QA agent. Let me just sign up for that. We would connect a call with you, figure out what tools that you actually have, coordinate everything, and then you're able to just take that use case, and then we just plug it up to your environment. And then we're also turning it into a monthly reoccurring product as well and figuring out what that looks like.
Two.
But.
What I'm trying to say is I think the AI piece of our company here is really going to be impactful, especially if you're already thinking about it. We've been really going deep. I know a lot of companies say they've been going pretty hard into AI, but I think everybody on this call would agree. I think we talk about
And we have individual optional calls that you can join, different projects that we're doing internally as well. So we're really, really focused on it. And then the governance and the training piece is huge as well. And teaching you how to just go to customers and talk about it. And that just builds the value there as well. And then that's when they start buying off of you.
So...
Okay.
And then for build it, are you thinking about coming to build it again?
False, it was in the buzzer last year. I don't know. I have to see if somebody else lets me come this year, so...
Well, I have a BOGO, so it's a buy one and get one. I'd love for both of you to come, to be honest. It'd be great to have both of you there.
I only.
Yeah.
But it's going to be a really great event. Same place as last year. It's going to be right on the Hudson view of New York City. Our offsite will be in New York City. Word is it's going to be the New York Stock Exchange, but it's not official official, but that's going to be pretty cool. The closing party will be there. Speaker is going to be John C. Maxwell and Dan Sullivan. So they're going to be our keynotes.
Stir.
should be having the actual agenda. AI is going to be a huge piece of it, but same as every year, we're doing the environmental scans and then we're building our breakout sessions around what the MSPs are looking for. You could also be a speaker if you want to come for free, you can be a speaker as well. So just let us know. I'll get you in touch with the people.
to be a speaker. If you want to be on any of the tech advisory panels, we can put you on those as well. And then again, we're giving a BOGO. So right now the price of the ticket is $1,500, but since you're a partner, we will give it another one for free. So buy one, get one. We'll put that code in the follow-up email here for you.
It's gonna be hard to compete with the birthday party last year.
Well, so then the rumor is that it's going to be Great Gatsby themed. So, you know, we had our India Atul, some of us, but I had it on. And the dancing, this one time, it's going to be a Great Gatsby. That's what I'm told. That'd be cool.
Oh.
Gotcha.
No, we'll make our best attempts. I'm gonna look at the calendar and work this out with Reggie.
Yeah, just block it right now. Make sure you guys don't have anything going on. Oh, and then the AI accelerator. So as far as the accelerator, it's going to be the last day, the 5th. So that's when we're really going to dive deep into like the revenue strategy, AI assessments, how to train your customers, and then how to turn that into a reoccurring revenue product.
PH.
So you'll definitely, and then that's when the party will be as well. And then we have the peer groups Sunday. So there's a Pre day with some peer groups too. We'll send that information out.
Okay.
I think that's all I have to talk about, but who knows?
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, that's that. Thanks, Natalie. All right, before we wrap it up, do you guys have any questions, concerns, want to talk about anything?
How's the weather where you guys are at?
Me or Natalie, you choose.
All of the above.
If it's Manila, it's like, we usually have this saying that in Manila, you just have two seasons. Hot or hotter. That's just it. That's enough.
Ohh.
So it's hotter this time. It's really humid. Humid hot. Yes.
And humid.
But.
Yeah, I'm in Texas, like Dallas, Texas, so I'm not, it's 70 here, so it's nice, but I still have my space heater on. I always laugh when people are like, oh, I like it warm. I'm originally from Pennsylvania. I'm originally from Pittsburgh. So I've been warm. Maybe eventually I'll get to the Philippines hot and hotter. That sounds great.
Natalie, yeah.
Stop.
Yeah, I know Pittsburgh has full winters, so you probably got out of there real quick.
PH.
Ohh.
Yeah, well, it was like 26. I had a few winters under my belt for sure. I believe they call them blizzards as well.
So.
In Lanzaga.
All right.
Great, Reggie, I gotta follow up with you on something.
Ohh.
Met you.
Yeah.
Jacob has the answer, but sure, go ahead, let's do it.
OK, so I wanna follow up with the with the bonus that we were talking about for Terrence quite some time, so...
So he knows about it. I'm aware of it. And I know it was discussed.
Yeah.
Yes.
Greg is still out of town until Monday, which I have a list of things to ask him about when he's back in town. So by Tuesday...
This is.
Ping, ping me on Teams and I'll have an answer for you on Tuesday.
You stay next. Sure. Thank you very much. That's all I need. That's all that is pending on my end.
So you can still message me and I can walk up on him and ask him as well. Or I'll bother Greg. I'll bother them both. So just whoever you get, I'll bother them both. I have a list of six things that Greg owes me answers on. So this is definitely on.
Yeah.
I gotcha.
Okay, got it. Just want to make sure that once Erin's asked me, I have that answer for Marty. But yep, I'll mark it on my calendar Tuesday. Gotcha.
Anything else you guys want to talk about?
I'm good. We're good. Yeah, I'm good.
Okay, perfect. So what I throw it out there on the 25th, it's the Memorial Day. It's an ITBD holiday. I just wanted to know if you will be needing Terrence to work on that day. Okay, cool. Oh, gotcha. I'll let him know and mark it as off. All right, I think that is pretty much it.
Nope, we're out to. We're out to. He's good.
Kour.
Thank you very much for your time. I think we have an early wrap up today. I'll give you the, I think 30 minutes or an hour of your time back. If you need anything, just holler.
Hey, will do. Thank you.
Thank you. Nice to meet you both.
Bye.
OK, well.
Bye, guys.
Guys, thank you.